If you were stranded on an desert island,
on an exoplanet, hundreds of years away from
Earth - how many people would you need with
you to survive?
Hey everyone, Emily here for DNews!
Elon Musk - founder of SpaceX - recently stated
that he wants to put 1 million people on Mars
within a century.
He’d bring everyone there with about a thousand
spaceships, each making multiple trips between
Earth and Mars.
If anything bad happened to threaten the existence
of this colony, we could quickly replenish
the population with a new batch of humans
sent from Earth.
This strategy works because it only takes
a few months to reach Mars.
But what if we wanted to colonize a world
beyond our solar system, hundreds of years
away?
How big of a spaceship would we need, and
how many humans would we need to start with
to make colonization possible?
Take Proxima B as an example.
It’s the closest planet we know about outside
of our solar system.
It’s rocky and similar in size to the Earth,
and has the potential to support liquid water
on its surface.
The problem is, we can’t just hop over there.
It’s 4 light-years away.
With current technology, it could take us
more than 20,000 years to get there.
That’s about 800 generations of humans - making
this type of journey fairly impossible.
Luckily, there are programs like the 100 Year
Starship project and Stephen Hawking’s Project
Starshot that are working to develop new propulsion
technologies that could get us there much
sooner - possibly within a few hundred years.
Assuming they’re successful, how many people
would we need to start a colony?
A study published in Acta Astronautica suggests
that you would need a starship filled with
at least 14,000 carefully screened people
to end up with a stable population after a
multi-century interstellar journey.
Even more people - up to 44,000 would ideal.
You’d have to account for potential catastrophes
like plague, asteroid strikes, or even war.
A few hundred years is a long time to be in
one spaceship - a lot of things could happen!
In the study, the researchers used population
genetics theory - modeling how the genetics
of a population changes over generations - and
accounted for one catastrophe during a 5-generation
voyage.
Populations over 14,000 maintain good health
during a trip of this length despite relatively
high inbreeding and reduced genetic diversity
over time.
As a colony, we’d need to do everything
we could to keep genetic diversity high - it’s
something that plays an essential role in
the adaptability and survival of a species.
Think about it - some humans would live out
their entire life on this interstellar spacecraft.
As a child, you would grow up - have kids
of your own with other passengers on board
- and eventually grow old and die.
But the only partners available to you would
be the limited number of members on board
the spacecraft.
You’d have to be extremely careful when
choosing your partner because inbreeding can
lead to some serious problems.
Just take a look at our early ancestors.
For thousands of years, Neanderthals, our
ancient cousins, lived in small, isolated
populations, which lead to inbreeding.
By studying their fossils, researchers have
discovered a range of deformities - many of
which are rare in modern humans.
An even larger issue with small populations
may be the community’s ability to formulate
their own culture, acquire knowledge and develop
technology.
The combination of these issues could lead
to the downfall of a species altogether.
We could have the same problems in a starship.
Maintaining a large population with sufficient
genetic diversity is key to a successful,
sustainable colonization of a new world.
Of course, a population of 14,000 is still
a lot of people, especially when you consider
the fact that the highest number of people
we’ve ever brought into space at once is
eight.
In order to meet that 14,000-human minimum
requirement - we’re going to need a bigger
ship.
Or.. many medium-sized ships.
Distributing your population across multiple
ships would also distribute the risk of losing
that population entirely.
And then maybe, you’d be able to distribute
the human species to another solar system.
But of course, all of this assumes that humans
can invent a propulsion system that’s 100
to 1,000 times faster than anything we have
today.
So perhaps, we should stick to the planets
in our own backyard for now.
Want to learn more about Proxima B?
Check out this video here.
What do you think?
Would you want to be part of that 14,000?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe and
come back here for more DNews everyday.